the old bet here and there but for some
the consequences are grave it was a huge
win I had when I was 29 life-changing
money
um and unfortunately it led me into the
deep dark
despair of a gambling addiction I just
don't understand
um in 2023
how this is still being allowed to
continue it's a bit like smoking 40 50
years ago policymakers have finally
taken action publishing a long-awaited
white paper that will crack down on a
thriving industry we need a new approach
that recognizes a flutter is one thing
unchecked Edition addiction is another
among the policies outlined are
a statutory Levy that will force
gambling companies to fund treatment of
addicts by the NHS new Financial checks
for gamblers who lose 125 pounds or more
in a month and even more rigorous checks
for those who lose a thousand pounds a
day and maximum Stakes for online slot
machines of two pounds for anyone aged
under 25 and 15 pounds for everyone else
for some it hasn't gone far enough with
tougher rules on Advertising noticeably
absent
but the industry said it was important
for the right balance to be struck we
pay 4.2 billion in tax and we have 22
and a half million customers who take
part in betting and gaming activities
regularly and on a monthly basis what's
important about this white paper is that
it's proportionate that it's
evidence-based and that it's balanced
but we will be working with government
to implement the changes that they have
put forward
is the biggest overhaul of gambling
rules in over a decade and while the
measures have been broadly welcomed the
wait isn't over just yet many of these
policies will go out for further
consultation and with the current
backlog of legislative business in
Westminster that could mean further
delays it's very simple take a pencil
preferably a red one and go consultation
no consultation no consultation no
statutory instrument yes statue
instrument yes statues are done
the work isn't done and in the meantime
gambling companies in Britain will
continue to enjoy one of the most
loosely regulated markets in the world
gurpreet narwan Sky News